[Music]
begin to suspend disbelief begin to look
at the things that you want to create
and take all that disbelief and
reorganize it reprogram it change your
perception around it because when we're
in that story of disbelief that's what
we're creating so take a minute to
really look at all the disbelief and
find a way to reframe it but reframe it
in a way that you believe it so if
you've got disbelief that you could
never lose that weight start to reframe
it with a belief system that's truthful
to you that's natural to you something
along the lines of i believe that i can
get to the gym every day and that's my
first step i believe that i have the
power to eat more healthfully so leaning
into a belief system that is real for
you that you can actually hold on to
that you can actually believe in because
if you start to use affirmations and
reframes that you don't believe in they
won't work that's just the bottom line
they won't work so reach for thoughts
that you believe in
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
attract things into your life enjoy
sit in a daily experience of
visualization visualize yourself going
to that gym visualize yourself in that
healthy body visualize yourself eating
that healthy meal and chewing it slowly
or visualize yourself on that date with
that partner that you long for or
visualize yourself working with the
people that you love to work with that
support you so much
and then the next and final
most important step is to allow that
visualization to become a feeling let
that visualization take over you
emotionally so you can genuinely feel a
connection to what you're seeing
so i allow my mind to wander and i see
myself and what it is that i desire and
then i let the feeling take over the
feeling of being taken care of the
feeling of being supported the feeling
of working and co-creating with people
that i love and and that's what i'm
currently visualizing and so being in
that feeling is what truly manifests
this into form
what's most awesome also is that you
start to feel what you want to create
even before it comes into form so it's
as if it's already happened and that's
actually the key point here which is
that you being in the energy of what it
is that you want to create actually
makes it so that it is there even if you
can't see it and you gotta believe it
before you see it as my teacher dr wayne
dyer always said rule number two rewire
your brain with john assaraf when you
have something in your brain that that a
neural network says well
uh what if this book comes out and you
fail what if it's not good enough what
is scientifically not correct what if
what if what if my brain is going to
process that the same way as your brain
and everybody else because that's
everybody's brain is the same the
mechanism of how the brain works it's
einstein's brain hitler's brain genghis
khan's brain
tom billio's brain john acetate all the
same functionality
so if you understand the mechanics of
what's supposed to happen
then you say okay great when i feel this
then what am i going to do
so i like to use an analogy of a car
you're driving a car
and you're talking to a friend of yours
and a light pops up on the dash you
don't take a hammer and hit a light
it's a signal something's happening
in the in the in the engine in the trunk
in the in the tires something's
happening emotions and feelings aren't
uh positive or negative
they're
empowering or disempowering to varying
degrees if you don't understand them
and so if you think about fear right
how does a firefighter
go into a burning building
when there's this enormous adrenaline
and an epinephrine you know that could
stop most people dead in their tracks
they learn here's the feeling
it's normal
do you have the knowledge and the skills
and the preparation to deal with this in
a safe way
go
if you don't now you retreat so we have
this phenomenal brain right it's it's
it's genius abilities we can't figure
out how to
replicate it anywhere with billions of
dollars
but we are getting some of the users
manual now
so when you feel fear what should you do
i teach the first two inner sizes that i
teach every one of our students number
one is called take six calm the circuits
so if you have this unpleasant anxious
fearful emotion energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant
and the breaks have gone on
if you just take six deep breaths in
through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem because what
happens when the stress response center
is activated blood goes away from that
into the fear response so you have
epinephrine cortisol adrenaline to be
able to get you out of this situation
it's part of our instinctual brain part
of the reptilian brain the first part of
the brain that was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain so when our brain has this signal
of oh my god you might get hurt you
might lose this you might get in trouble
you might be embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged et cetera
that part of the brain is going to get
activated so if you take six deep
breaths first calm down calm the
circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
ayah aia
the first day is for awareness
what am i thinking right now what am i
feeling right now what am i sensing
right now what is my behavior right now
to you thoughts feelings sensations
awareness of behavior what's my
intention right now that's the i
well my intention is to move forward i
want to do this
great what's one
very small action step that you can take
now the reason you want to take one
small action step
is one small action step
your brain can handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat response goes away
but if you focus on the end game right
away
you're gonna get that rush and that
instant trigger of the fear response
stress response so the first thing you
want to do is learn how to manage your
mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior more than anything else
because we move away from pain and we
move towards pleasure but we move away
from pain a thousand times faster
and pain wires in the brain faster for
survival mechanisms
so purely from a neuroscience
perspective just understanding self
once you understand okay this feeling is
normal okay what should i do
take six con the circuits
ayah
and now you can start being progressive
and make progress towards what you want
now while you're in the you know in the
uh what am i thinking feeling it's a
chance to be aware and the biggest gift
we have as human beings
is our awareness
because awareness is what gives you
choice and choice is what gives you
freedom
most people are living their lives in a
reactive state automatic reactive state
because of these set points that we
talked started talking about so we're in
this repetitive cycle over and over and
over and over we react to the same
things we behave the same way we eat the
same foods we dress the same way
just to maintain that homeostasis and
comfort zones and we've never been
taught like when were we taught as kids
like here are your six core emotions
here's the way you deactivate you know
your stress center or fear so here's how
you activate your imagination center
here's how you have more focus here's
how you develop a new belief here's how
you develop a new habit here's how you
release one we haven't been taught that
we've been told they're important things
but we haven't been given the tools
and then we haven't practiced the tools
enough to be able to make them part of
our unconscious competence brain rule
number three use the power of
objectivity with mel robbins hey it's
mel and i am so excited to share this
very simple surprising and shockingly
powerful trick that you can use if you
ever find yourself feeling stuck
when you're manifesting feeling like you
can't
visualize the steps that lead you to
what you want is an extraordinarily
common obstacle when you're manifesting
because remember manifesting is the
practice of preparing your mind body and
spirit to do the work to achieve the
things that you want and as you probably
know
manifesting has four different parts to
it first of all you got to give yourself
permission to really
have what you want okay because you got
to have the thing that you're
visualizing be something that is
authentically something that you want
number two you must see yourself taking
the steps the tiny actions and doing the
work that will lead you to creating or
having what you want
third you got to feel in your body what
it feels like to do the work and you
also have to feel pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really
imprinting and training and preparing
for it and fourth
obviously you got to take the actions
and all of that manifesting and
preparing inspires you to take the
actions
but one place where so many folks get
stuck when they start trying to make
manifesting a daily habit
is you go and you know what you want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there
and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you i'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend mel robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire and the
power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now i'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the harvard business
school review they did eight different
studies at the university of wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves
doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay i want you to imagine
yourself asking for a raise or applying
for that dream job when you visualize
yourself doing it you immediately focus
in on minutia you start imagining all
kinds of things that could go wrong you
start arguing against yourself and doubt
comes flooding in you have a very
cautious mindset when you place yourself
in those scenarios
however
if you were to visualize me mel robbins
asking for that raise
immediately your mindset switches to
being very bold being creative seeing
all kinds of opportunities and in fact
when you not only visualize me your
friend mel robbins asking for that raise
that you want when you give me advice
you're super enthusiastic you're like
mel you should go for it and i bet in
your life
you have probably
told friends or loved ones you should
ask for more money and you mean it
because you're visualizing them but you
yourself
won't visualize yourself doing that you
talk yourself out of it we've all had
this experience you yourself are
probably sitting there going right now i
constantly tell my friends you deserve
more you should break up with that jerk
you should go for it
but when it comes to yourself
you see the excuses in depth so i want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend mel robbins or insert
anybody that you love in fact i got a
story about this
years and years ago
this would have been god 20 years ago
at the time i was a life coach and i had
a really small little practice here in
boston
and i went to a seminar that oprah
winfrey had here at the boston
convention center it was part of her
like live your best life tour and i went
to the seminar because i thought well
this would be a great place to land life
coaching clients right you got thousands
of women at the convention center who
all want to improve your life so i can
go and i can network and who knows i
might meet some amazing women and meet
some amazing business partners and land
some clients so i'm sitting in the
audience
and you know the dj starts playing the
music and everybody gets out of their
chairs we all start dancing around with
our name tags on and then all of a
sudden the dj
dies down the music and we all settle
down and this woman walks on the stage
now i didn't recognize this woman i
didn't have my program on my hands i had
no idea who it was i had never seen her
before i had never heard her before when
they announced her name not a clue all i
knew
was when she started talking
something inside me was like
energetically something shifted
i bet you've had those moments where
you're like
boom
you know
that something is meant for you
you just feel pulled toward like you can
have this experience with a piece of
clothing with a house with a puppy with
a person with an experience with a place
well this woman walks on stage and i had
this energetic shift that was like
and i immediately felt my body go
you need to be doing that but what i saw
was
she's on a stage
she's clearly an author
she's making people laugh she's
inspiring oh my gosh she's a life coach
well this person i'm talking about is
none other than martha beck i didn't
know her at the time but she's an
international best-selling author she
writes for o magazine she was clearly
speaking on a stage and guess what
she was oprah's designated life coach
and so i have this energetic shift where
i'm like i want to be doing that
i i want to go from
just coaching individual clients to
having an impact on a much bigger scale
now keep in mind at the time i
have only been
coaching people for two or three years
i've never given a speech i had never
written an article in a magazine i
didn't have a book i didn't know how to
do any of those things but i went home
from that uh seminar and i sat down and
i cracked open my journal and i'm like i
want to speak on stages i want to write
things for magazines i want to write a
book i want to impact millions of people
i want to do what martha beck is doing i
didn't know how to do any of it and so i
developed this simple tool now little
did i know i was just instinctively
leveraging the power of objectivity
since i didn't know what to do and i
also didn't know who to ask because 20
years ago i didn't know a single person
that had published a book i didn't know
anybody that wrote for magazines i
didn't know anybody that spoke on stages
for a living and i certainly didn't know
anybody that knew oprah so i didn't even
have anybody that i could ask there
weren't as many articles online so it's
not like i could blog youtube was not
really a thing so it's not like i could
watch videos i mean you know how lucky
you are to be able to research all this
stuff i was just me mel robbins with a
handful of clients here in boston now
inspired to do what martha's back doing
with no clue how to go from here to
there i didn't know the steps so i came
up with this little tool
it's so funny when i think about it now
do you want to know what the tool was
what would martha beck do
i said
what would martha beck do because i
figured
mel robbins had never done any of those
things
but martha beckham so in any moment
where i didn't know what i should do i
just figured i would ask myself well
what would martha beck do and i kind of
thought that maybe if i acted like she
acted maybe i would eventually start to
steer my life in the direction that her
life was headed in in terms of writing
books and standing on stages 20 years
ago so i was leveraging the power of
objectivity so this is what happened a
couple weeks go by and nothing
miraculous happens in my life and i get
an email and i'm up late and i'm working
on something and this email comes in and
the email
is from a friend of mine who works in
new york hadn't seen her in a while but
she knew that i was a life coach and i
noticed
that she was forwarding a pr request
from ink magazine and kate wrote to me
hey mel
not sure if you're still life coaching
but see below someone is writing an
article about life coaching for inc
magazine
thought you may be interested in
applying so i scroll down and i
immediately start to read the email now
there are a couple things that jumped
out immediately right number one the pr
request was over a month old number two
the deadline had already passed
for submissions to be featured in the
article number three i had none of the
credentials that they were looking for
for life coaches number four i had none
of the types of clients that they were
looking for
now
thinking about it from mel robbins point
of view
my mind got very cautious and i started
to focus on all the minutia
i'm too late i'm not qualified
i've missed the deadline they're never
going to pick me
self-doubt's starting to creep in just
like it's happening for you when you
manifest right now your mind is going
blank you're full of doubt which is why
you can't see the steps
i in that moment
ask myself well i know what mel robbins
would do mel robbins would hit delete
and go on with her evening
but what would martha beck do
the second i leveraged the power of
objectivity and i imagined her in the
situation that i was in my mind got more
creative it got bolder it got more
energized i saw a possibility i
literally said to myself well what have
i got the lows martha back would
probably just respond and so i did i
just free-formed the thing i wrote this
long email
and i hit send do you know the very next
morning
the person that had sent the inquiry out
wrote me back and said i've already
finished the article i was about to
submit it but i was so taken with your
email
that i'd love to come up to boston
and follow you around for a day and
include you in the article and it was
that article which published about five
months later
that caught the attention
of a bunch of people in the media
business in new york
and that's what caused this major pivot
that happened in my career honest to god
it was the power of objectivity and
simply asking myself what would martha
beck do so
super common to feel super stuck
when you know what you want but you
can't visualize yourself taking those
steps because
you're thinking cautious your self-doubt
is consuming you
you are insecure in your ability to
actually do those things so you can't
even embrace
the visualization of yourself doing it
simple
insert someone else and you can always
pick your friend mel robbins also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four
nerd with brendan burchard i get asked
so many questions about like how do you
do all these things and how do how do
you achieve a long-term dream not just
get stuff done and be more productive on
a monday and tuesday but like move
yourself
to bigger and bigger goals and dreams in
your life and i'd love to share that
with you i got four big ideas for you
the the first one is obviously you gotta
see yourself
in scenes
in your life that don't currently exist
and what i mean by that is you've got to
visualize specific scenes that you would
love to manifest in your life in the
future um maybe you guys know i'm from
montana right i'm from this tiny irish
mining town uh that was economically
depressed for a century by the time i
got there and my parents you know
raising us four kids i literally don't
know how they
made it i don't know how they supported
us and we really really struggled
but
somehow i always could
visualize things for myself and i i
remember thinking one time when i got to
college i was like you know i would love
one day to live on a beach and i would
love to like get up in the morning
go walk on the beach swim a little bit
in the ocean have a nice breakfast sit
down with my journal and then go about
the day i i could see myself talking
with people and new cultures and
traveling i could see myself being
somebody who was a person of influence
in some way or another and i had no idea
how all that was going to manifest but i
did not fear to dream or when the
visions came in i didn't like stop them
and say well that's stupid because i'm
just a kid from a poor town
i did not know that one day i could live
on my dream beach
that was not the point
it was that i saw the scenes and i
allowed to dream about them
you have a lot of visions and you have a
lot of dreams that you have where you
just go well that's stupid or i don't
like that or what would they think or
who am i to do that and i'm here to tell
you explore those visions maybe you were
given those visions and those visions
were a gift to you that you're supposed
to manifest
and so what i'd love for you to do is
think out 10 years 20 years
30 years and just try to imagine scenes
in your life because what most people do
is they don't see scenes in their life
they just write down to-do lists and
goals
and so every day it's about a to-do list
and they're trying to just be more
effective and productive each week
but they're not seeing the bigger
picture so even though they're getting
their to-do lists done they got a lot of
goals they're not excited they're not
enthusiastic they they don't have that
vision pulling them forward and so see
the scenes that you might have in the
future with your family you know see the
scenes that you would have in your
personal lifestyle like how do you live
what do you do where do you go see the
scenes of yourself performing or doing
your work or your career see the scenes
of yourself happy and fit and healthy
and explore those and i mean
every day
like visualization isn't something you
do once in a while on a birthday or when
it's new years it's like every day so
you guys know i wake up every morning
and i stretch for about 15 or 20 minutes
if i don't do my morning workout
then i read some motivation or
inspiration for 20 minutes then i sit
down with my high performance planner i
write down my day and then i push away
from having writ down that and now i
just start seeing the scenes of the day
how can i do them with joy and
excellence i start visualizing a bigger
picture and seeing just what comes in
about my future i'm consistently engaged
in
future thinking
future envisioning and it's not like
everything has come true
but i'll show you know
the the scene that we're in right here
from montana to this scene i envisioned
20
years ago
think about that 20 years ago i was like
i'm going to live on a beach one day
when i lived in montana in the mountains
as far away as possible i am telling you
more is possible than you actually know
right now the second big idea i want to
share with you in order to achieve that
after you envision it in order to
actually get there sometimes you're
gonna have to prioritize skill building
over
stability
and what i mean by that is maybe
you you have this idea that you're gonna
have this dream career one day
well maybe you're gonna have to be an
intern first and be barely able to
afford rent to build up the skills that
would deserve and grow you into that
career
right we we have to think about okay in
order to have this vision that i have
what specific skills would i need to
develop
this year next year over the next five
years over the next 10 years to get
there you know i was a kid that was kind
of awkward well i still am awkward but i
was like i was the kid who i just i was
kind of happy go lucky but i just i was
kind of scared of people because where i
grew up there was a lot of abuse and a
lot of people smack people around where
i grew up
so i had to get over that i thought you
know i'm gonna be a great communicator
one day
so i started taking classes on
communication reading books on
communication you know reading the
classics like how to win friends and
influence people or how to be a positive
thinker or how to be a person of
influence and lead others and i just
started studying communication when i
wanted to do this work i had no idea how
to do video i didn't know how to do
podcasting i never learned html yet i
didn't know about a blog i didn't know
how to do an event at a venue let alone
you know the thousands of people now
that come to our events
i had to put that on my skill building
sheet and say okay there's going to be
times that i'm going to prioritize skill
building over having a stable job or
having you know a stable income or
having like a stable like i know exactly
how every week is going to go because i
was going to be a collector of skills
i was going to have that vision and go
like collect all the skills to get there
even if in the short term sometimes
it was hard
it makes sense so make a list of all the
skills you need to develop and then you
have to ask yourself are you willing to
compromise your lifestyle a little bit
to develop those skills
sometimes that means working for less
pay sometimes that means going and
getting a mentor and working with a
company and and just starting from the
ground up to develop skill but your
skill set
is the pathway to the greater visions of
life
the third thing i think you have to do
which most people don't talk about you
have to build your network
you got to build your network i like i'm
here because i've told a bajillion
people like one day i'd love to live on
a beach and i tell people in my network
and you know maybe they had a job that
was related or not related maybe they
knew people who lived on beach maybe
they didn't but everybody around me
always knew the things i wanted to
achieve i want to write a book i want to
be a speaker i want to do podcasting i
want to shoot on youtube i want to you
know be a person who gets to share
about life transforming ideas and tools
that inspired me
that's what i want to do with my life i
want to help people achieve their dreams
faster and improve their lives and i
would tell everybody that even though i
started talking about that when
i was broke i was struggling i was
trying to get my morning routines and my
habits together and my health together i
was gonna get my mind together it wasn't
like i had everything figured out but i
let people know along the journey what i
wanted
and i thought about the people who would
i have to be friends with what type of
people would i have to know in my
industry
in order to help me achieve the
abundance to make my dreams come true
so what are the exact types of people
you need to know and i mean what i want
you to think is like who would you love
to have on speed dial on your phone
like the people of your influence the
people in your industry oh you want to
do you want to be a filmmaker great who
are the great directors you would love
to get to meet and have on speed dial on
your phone right you want to have a job
in this career or that industry who are
the industry leaders and titans who you
would love to have on speed dial and
make it like a game
to get to meet those people add value to
those people befriend those people serve
those people or work for those people so
that now you're in that world because if
you don't know the networks you need to
achieve your dreams your dreams are
really going to be far away so build the
network you need now
and i would say you know the last big
idea that comes to me is that you must
make bold moves
sooner than later
i mean here's the truth when i was
living here in montana i envisioned
myself living in the caribbean some day
on a beautiful beach 20 years ago i
envisioned that
if i could go back
why did i wait 20 years to move here
because i thought all these conditions
had to happen before i could have the
thing and i'm here to tell you sometimes
the real trick is to put yourself in
play in the dream sooner than later
right you want to be a world famous
tennis player well don't think that you
need to go do 50 things what you need to
do is get yourself on the tennis court
every day you want to live on a beach
move to a beach yeah maybe you're living
in a tent or a shack at first but you're
on the beach and you're putting yourself
in the motion of the dream right you
want to be a filmmaker film every day
right you want to be i mean you think
about like the greats you think about
like a you know like a steven spielberg
i mean he was shooting every day as a
kid it wasn't like he was waiting one
day to have a producer come along and
say let's make a movie kid he just
started
and that's what you have to do whatever
your dream is please don't be like me
and wait 20 years to access it what i
should have done is just moved earlier
but i thought well no this condition and
then i'll make this and then i'll build
that and the team will be here
and it was like now that i'm here i'd
walk around and go look at this
beautiful place why didn't i come here
earlier
so i hope that serves you you've got
more capabilities and potential in you
than most people ever tell you and most
people will tell you oh your dream's
stupid i'm here to tell you visualize it
i'm here to tell you skill up for it get
that network and get yourself in place
sooner than later because you can
achieve extraordinary things but as my
wife always says you can choose to be
ordinary today or you can choose to be
extraordinary so i say visualize my
friends and go make it happen rule
number five frame your dream with marie
forleo if you've ever lost motivation
because you're afraid your dreams are
just too
unrealistic
this one is for you today's question
comes from bree who writes
hey marie you're such an inspiration i
so respect your advice thank you
here's my situation my whole life i've
had big dreams and lots of ambition then
this little word started to pop up from
people around me
unrealistic for example i wanted to work
in publishing i was told that was
unrealistic there were so many obstacles
and so few jobs however i now work for
the second largest publishing company in
the world but there's a new dream i want
to pursue and i can already hear the
cacophony of voices in my head insisting
this dream is unrealistic
a certain level of realism is necessary
but too much can create self-doubt so
marie how do i handle not only hearing
from others how unrealistic my dream is
but also not let myself drown out my own
desires thank you so much free
i love this question so much brie every
single one of us who both dreams and
creates things faces voices of dissent
both from people that we know from
people that we don't know and very often
the most deadly comes from within and if
we don't take a thoughtful conscious
approach to taking on our unrealistic
dreams they just ain't gonna happen but
if you are up for the challenge and i
think you are here are five steps that
can help
step number one is frame your dream and
here's what this means we can't become
what we can't envision so when i say
frame your dream what i mean is i want
you to take a picture of it in your
mind's eye
in vivid specific detail and then what i
want you to do is translate that picture
into words meaning write down that big
unrealistic dream and i know that you
may have heard about the power of
writing things down before but the truth
is most people just don't do it which is
so crazy because the research is
conclusive on this there was a study
done by dr gail matthews that shows that
you are 42
more likely to achieve your goals if you
write them down so what i want you to do
is whip out your journal or hop on that
keyboard and get writing step number two
is filter opinions and fend off
negativity you've got to take
responsibility for the energy that you
allow in your life i want you to fend
off negativity as much as humanly
possible
you know we know so much more about the
brain than we did just 20 years ago
neuroscience has taught us incredible
things like that our brains are
continuously shaped by our thoughts and
our experiences and you know this to be
true i mean negativity is one of the
most toxic forces on the planet it's
toxic for your brain for your nervous
system and for your ability to stay
motivated so do me this favor okay
do not solicit or listen to the opinions
of people who are notorious for just
being debbie downers the one mistake
that i've seen people make consistently
is they almost habitually talk to the
exact person who is the most likely to
shoot them down and make them feel like
crap so don't do that and here's another
key i want you to always always always
consider the source meaning don't put a
lot of stock into other people's
opinions unless they're actually out
there consistently taking risks and
being brave and actually making things
happen i mean if you think about it
let's say i don't know you wanted to
climb mount everest would you ever take
advice from someone who's never even
attempted the summit no of course not
that would be crazy so don't take advice
from anyone unless you really think it
through and i want you to ask
has this person achieved an unrealistic
or impossible dream
are they taking meaningful risks on a
consistent basis
do you admire who they are how they live
and what they contribute if not do not
use them as a sounding board for your
idea
step number three is flood yourself with
positive examples so
once you've removed the negative outputs
as best as you can
step number three is all about feeding
your mind and surrounding yourself with
positive stories on a consistent basis
of other people who have achieved
unrealistic dreams so think about helen
keller for example who was blind and
deaf by the age of two yet with the help
of teachers she created this
extraordinary literary career writing
hundreds of speeches and essays and
books then there are thousands of
biographies at the library or even on
netflix and the great thing that i love
about biographies is you also get a
chance to witness other people's
stumbles and their falls and all the
failures that they experience along the
way which of course stumbles and falls
and failures those are inevitable for
all of us and you know
it's worth noting that just about anyone
whose achievements are worthy of a
biography or a documentary probably had
an unrealistic dream
so do this for me feed your mind
examples of people who speak out and
stand up for what they believe in and
make change happen
step number four is fast forward so if
you've watched the show for any amount
of time you know this i love end of life
studies and here's what we know for a
fact when you're on your deathbed you
couldn't care less about what anybody
who says your dreams are unrealistic
says i mean brony ware's research tells
us this very very clearly that the
single biggest regret people have when
they're about to pass is this
i wish i had the courage to live a life
true to myself
not the life others expected of me
so bree my friend stop worrying about
what other people might think or say
about how unrealistic your dream is
it really does not matter the only thing
that matters is what you do about it now
step number five is focus on action so
this my friend is the most important
step of all action is the antidote to
fear and you don't have to take perfect
action you just need to take any action
brick by brick inch by inch step by step
that is how all great things are
achieved and you know my mantra i
believe everything is
outable and the best way to figure
anything out is through action-based
learning so one more thing before we
wrap up brie
unrealistic dreams are totally where
it's at that's where all the growth and
the excitement in life comes from after
all what other kind of dreams are there
rule number six control your thoughts
with dean graziosi what's standing
between you and where you want to go is
always the story between it
you're next level there's only a story
between you there's no physical guard
there's no guns there's no blockade it's
what's going on in here and when you can
understand that your thoughts can make
you have a great day or a bad day when
you understand that your thoughts are
things
and they're not true in most cases your
thoughts lie to you i literally had this
conversation with my dad about a month
ago i said have your thoughts ever lied
to you he's like i don't think so i said
no i said ever in your life think um
someone you were dating didn't like you
anymore they were actually talking to
someone else and it wasn't true he's
like oh yeah i remember this story did
you ever think a friend cheated you or
ignored you or didn't call you to go to
the movies and you got upset and got
worked up and then it wasn't true
yeah and i named like ten things he's
like yeah your thoughts lied to you i
said of course they do over and over
again but you could step back and check
that thought and just make it a habit i
am not perfect at this but i obsess on
it every day when i'm in a good mood i
want to observe what i'm thinking so i
can have more of that when i'm worried
stressed or a little anxious i want to
know what those thoughts are what makes
me anxious when i feel like i have
everything i ever wanted why am i
anxious today and i look and go holy
crap that thought's been hanging around
since i was 14.
that one's got to go
so i want to give you a little story
it's the greatest gift that you could
give your family yourself and your
company
for the next week obsess on everything
that you do after the fact and observe
what your thinking was to actually make
it happen
and i want to simplify it again i always
want to tell you i'd love to give you
all these things and say you can go do
them all in life's perfect i understand
you're busy you got life you've got a
million different influences so i want
to give you the things that you could
just plop in and not make a big deal out
of it just observe your thinking good
mood just step back say why am i in a
good mood bad mood step back and just
look at the thought i want to give an
example
of because i've been obsessed on this
mostly the last 18 months
kind of obsessed for five years
obsessively 18 months last six months
ridiculously
obsessed so i'm at breakfast with my
kids
and
my son has this crazy memory so he's got
these crayons a box of like 40 crayons
and they're not like red blue and pink
they're like
lime lime green tequila gold like
they're all these exotic names right and
he's loving these crayons and he pulls
one out and he goes dad look at this
color i'm like oh that's cool is that
green he goes no it's lime exotic
tequila gold i don't know i'm making
that [ __ ] up um
but so he remembers it and i'm like wow
you remember that one and he pulls out
another one like what's that one and i
grabbed the box from him and i go
through this this little guy remembered
all 40 names i couldn't remember all 40
if i studied for six months
so i'm like dude that's amazing that's
your gift that's unique ability my
daughter's sitting there sees all the
praise he's getting and says i can do
that i'm like
that's not your unique ability god gives
us all unique abilities dad couldn't do
it but you're my inventor you're the
visionary my son's the implementer if
they ever would like each other enough
to be partners they'll be badass
so
so my daughter goes in the other room
she studies she goes no i got this pull
the first one out what do you think
she gets it wrong and like bri we all
and she starts crying that's not like
her she's like upset and i'm like baby
no no no i said you have a gift brody
doesn't come up with the ideas you have
i'm like so i tell her about her gifts
and she blurts out and she says it's
because you spend more time with brody
in the
morning like oh
so me thinking i'm doing this right i
said brianna
don't tell yourself a lie
and don't tell me a lie i spend equal
time with you two
and i go in that phase right
and all of a sudden she tucks it down
she goes from crying tucks it down she
gets dressed and she gets ready and it's
the first day she left since she was
born without giving me a kiss going off
to school and i'm like it's all right
she's learning a lesson until she left
and like an hour later i'm walking
around and i do what i'm sharing with
you i observed my thinking and i'm like
oh
like literally just like that i'm not
kidding you
and i'm like i just told my daughter her
feelings don't matter
that's what i told her she tried to
express whether right wrong or other
ways that's how she felt in that moment
and what i told her was your feelings
don't matter tuck it down go to school
if she gets married to a guy who does it
to her i'll kick his ass
and if he's bigger than me i'm italian
i'll someone kick his ass
and all of a sudden i'm feeling this and
i'm like oh my god i literally got in my
car i blew a couple red lights i drove
90 miles an hour i got to her school
because the best way to fix stuff is
just fix it right not think about it
because i observe this thought again i'm
just giving you this lesson of what it
does for you because you can observe
these things like like a third party so
i get to the school and there's two
people waiting in the line at the
principal's office so you're supposed to
get the little tag and put the name
thing on and sign in like the hell with
i jumped the fence
and i ran across the the
field where they all play right the
playground and i'm like imagine if
teacher sees me it's gonna be 9-1-1 air
raid like there's a security guard at
the school is going to tackle me i could
care less i literally jumped to six foot
fence
i knock on her door she comes out like
baby dad made a bad parenting decision
your feelings matter to me i got on my
knees i'm like baby your feelings matter
whether you believe that or not thank
you i said whether you believe it
whether i believed you or not whether it
was true or not doesn't matter that's
the way you felt in the moment i should
have acknowledged your feelings dad was
wrong and we talked we hugged we kissed
i literally left sobbing like a like
like i was like bye baby
like literally sobbing and then i was in
a great mood i had the radio cranking i
felt amazing
but it never would have happened if i
wasn't the observer of my thoughts
and i'm not great at it i'm not perfect
at it but make it a part of your life
and watch how your life changes wherever
it is you want to go when you have that
vision remember what's standing in your
way is nothing more than a thought and i
tell people all the time i'll sell the
i'll say to my daughter she's like but i
don't think it should give me the story
i'm like
can you go grab me that story in the
other room
can you go grab me that thought
no you can't grab it it's only in here
brie or brody it's only in here so let's
just change that thought and all of a
sudden there's nothing in your way
because it's not physical
it's in here and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is visualize the end goal with
greg louganis when you're teaching about
visualization with these at these dive
camps or any other athletes you're
training one-on-one
how do you translate
what you learned and experienced
visually with imagery because i believe
in visualization i did it for many years
how do you translate teaching
that emotion that feeling to get in the
flow what do you tell people well the
first thing
with visualization and i i learned
through trial and trial and error
because i learned visualization when i
was three wow you know uh and that was
i'm sure by accident
my dance instructor said okay visualize
yourself no no she didn't say visualize
she said okay um imagine yourself doing
the routine
and she played the music left the room
i was only three years old so i was like
okay you know that's how i interpreted
it
and so that's how i learned
visualization and then later on i
learned relaxation exercises when i was
going through puberty it was like you
know
i was
suffering from anxiety and stress
related stuff
i also had asthma
and so
what i learned in teaching
visualization
to dog agility people
ballroom dancers
water polo players
divers
i had to start with relaxation i had to
teach them the relaxation actually
breathe
take them through the relaxation
exercises
then they would be
have
a better opportunity for success in
their visual visualization work
the one thing when i
start somebody with visualization work
is that i start with something
totally
away from
whatever activity they're wanting to
visualize
so like what
well i have several i have several kind
of fun exercises um
i think
let's see there's a roller coaster ride
there's a horse
riding a horse
uh and
i think the one that i
those those two
um
because okay it's it's a wild exciting
roller coaster ride and i try and get
them to use all of their senses which is
feeling were they smelling what are they
hearing
you know what do they taste um
you know because when that adrenaline
starts amping up then you know you can
get dry mouth yeah yeah
and
so those
the horse ride in the and the roller
coaster really taps into the adrenaline
the one that i really enjoy especially
with kids is i told them okay you're
gonna bake some cookies oh i was like
okay pick somebody
that you
you know that you want to bake cookies
with you know whether it's your mom your
best friend your aunt your uncle who
mount whomever pick whoever it is so
there's an emotional connection
to that person and then i go through the
measuring of the um the sugar and the
flour and the
texture of the butter and
the smell of the
extract you know whether it be vanilla
or almond or whatever it is
so they go through all of their senses
the sense of smell
taste and all of that stuff
and i try and encourage them to use all
of their senses because you never know
what's going to come
out to the forefront yeah as far as
their strength
um
and so
you know and that's that's how i teach
visualization that it's totally removed
from what the activity is
because that's important because if it
goes wrong in the activity
that they're
you know
wrong in
[Music]
so you have them practice something
other activity first
you have them relax breathe go through
another activity of visualization then
you take them to the dive or to the
sport after necessarily
no i mean i i let them hang out there
and then it's it's almost like
you know you
they're muscles
you know that you're flexing and yeah
and so you're
using to utilize so the more that you
flex those muscles and the more fun that
you can have in doing it the more likely
you are to practice and and do it yeah
so then you play along play along play
along it's like oh mate you know let's
try this you know they they come to the
conclusion on their own usually
that okay i'm ready for this and then
their visualization kind of
steps right into place that's powerful
yeah i've never heard someone talk about
visualizing another activity first yeah
to tighten your senses
and then step into yours when you're
ready yeah so i like that that's a great
yeah i'm gonna start doing that
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some
giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel
and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history
it took so many years guys so many years
of just making content and not seen any
results
i took i forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost 2 million
subscribers and i was sitting over 3
million subscribers etc
i haven't missed
an upload
every single day
for i don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
i've made videos through
travel i've made videos through
elect electricity electricity outages i
made videos through breaking my neck i
made videos through my tour i made
videos through vacation i made videos i
made videos i made videos i made videos
i made videos on my videos and you can
plan you could prepare you can get ahead
you can
you can batch them
but i don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested
that's when you have to show yourself
what you're made of
even little things like
i remember filming at my dance studio in
toronto
and i have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming
and the electricity goes out
and then there's a fire line
they go i guess we can't film like the
first thing that
that my camera guy says is okay well i
guess we can't film i can't film with
this like electricity outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm
like you can't film with that it's like
i'm i'm filming today
so i took my phone it was freezing
outside i took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
i've made videos with my broken neck
i broke my neck and two spots had a
concussion
and i
next week i'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
i'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos i'm wearing this giant
neck brace i got this giant scab here on
my forehead because i smashed my head
against the wall
when i fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck i'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted and shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego
who
i still don't like being on stage i
still get nervous every single time
but i still have a message
and i still want to serve how does
somebody
like that
have this kind of channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos i've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy not all of
them are public
but even just on the main channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 plus videos
over
12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
i think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
we're really if you just stayed on it
like you've guys you've had ideas you
haven't you've you have had an idea that
you loved you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and i get
it i'm there too i'm i'm impatient i
want immediate results i want things to
happen i'm putting my best i want this
video right now to be the best one i've
ever done and i put my effort to try to
make that happen and i fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily
consistent
action
to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life
number one you have to create a calendar
these videos happen because you're in my
calendar
i'm filming this on a tuesday
tuesday is my youtube day
i always film on tuesday i block it off
in my calendar
i just came back from vacation
and on the tuesday of my week i was
still making videos people say well
still work on vacation first off it's
not work like i like this this is fun
for me this isn't this isn't i have to
go make videos if that was my mindset i
would
i'd be out i wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that i invested into
yesterday how do i take a vacation on my
business
like how do i my wife wants to know how
do i go on vacation to run this business
like you can still you can either plan
ahead and get ahead with all your
clients or you can still do some work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working
it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have in the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional
most of your vacation time is not
intentional either if you were to spend
21 hours a day with your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
is easy as nothing
so of course you can take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream i could say i
want to make youtube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too
every
uh every afternoon
at 2 30 i spend time with nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning i take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we
we stay inside and just be together if
it's raining like we'll spend time every
day every week at 2 30 because i want i
wanted to spend more time with nina
during the week weekends we're basically
all in on on the relationship but the
weekdays can be crazy you know so we
spend time in the morning we spend time
in the evening and i wanted to spend
2 30.
it's 25 minutes together but intentional
25 minutes that intentional 25 minutes
is worth more than three hours to just
sit in front of a tv that's not time
together
you have a lot more time than you think
you're just not being intentional that's
the problem
if you feel like you got the end of the
week and you were so busy but you got
nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
i'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip i'm a little jet
lagged
from coming out from the west
i'm still making videos i'm still
videos have to be made they're going up
like when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today i don't care
if i'm lying in bed i don't care
i don't care if i'm in the hospital i've
made videos from the hospital i don't
care where videos have to come up i
don't care if they're the best videos
the best
with what i can make right now
if i'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what i can make
right now if i'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what i can make
out of the hospital but i'm gonna make
the best of what i can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're going to do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we say
you're going to get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up and say i'm not i can't do
that i'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more i follow through i
follow through i follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay i'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and so it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself
you're gonna make a hundred videos a day
every day
you're gonna make a thousand phone calls
a day every day
you're not you're gonna write a hundred
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not gonna
happen make it a realistic plan
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why i
create the entspresso to be with you
every morning to give you the boost to
bring you people like john ashraf and
oprah and elon musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams who are trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today i'm supposed to do that
the god i want to do that
what brings you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions
to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to activate the power of
manifestation check the video right
there next to us i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and we'll see you
there
if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship then i'm gonna feel so
great well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen